there these are the what are called the
reciprocal identities because you can
see like sign is the reciprocal of
cosecant or cosecant is the reciprocal
of sine cosine and secant are
reciprocals of each other
tangent and cotangent so you can see how
they're paired up with one another and
that'll cut down on some of the
memorization that you'll need to do
tangent is sine over cosine cotangent is
cosine over sine and then we've got the
three Pythagorean trig identities sine
squared plus cosine squared equals one
and then you get these other two what
you can do is if you take the basic
Pythagorean trig identity and you divide
all of these quantities by sine squared
you'll get this one and if you divide
all these by cosine squared you'll get
this identity so if you know this one
you'll be able to find these other two
and then here what we have are the KO
functions and again what you can do is
you can pair these up like sine of 90
minus the angle equals cosine cosine of
90 minus angle of sine so sine and
cosine are Co function pairs tangent and
cotangent are Co function pairs secant
and cosecant go together these ones here
are what are called the even and odd
identities and what you'll notice here
is that sine cosecant tangent and
cotangent are odd and what that means is
that if you're taking the sine of a
negative angle it has the same value as
the sine of a positive angle but it'll
have the opposite sign so if this is
negative then be negative times a
negative would be positive so the signs
will be the opposite but cosine and
secant they're the same so the cosine of
a negative angle will be the same as the
cosine of the positive angle they'll be
exactly the same and if you want to
understand some of these a little bit
deeper I can show you a little bit more
about it like say for example if you had
a triangle like this if you go this
direction that's positive if you go this
direction that's negative and what
you'll notice is C cosine on the unit
circle is the x-coordinate so whether
you go counterclockwise or clockwise the
same number of degrees these triangles
are going to be exactly congruent and
the x-values going to be the same
but notice the y-value this is positive
this is negative and that's why you can
see sign of a negative angle is the
opposite from the sign of a positive
angle so you can draw diagrams like
these another one with the co functions
okay is like this if you have a right
triangle and this is Theta this will be
90 minus theta okay because these two
angles add up to 90 so if you do the
sine sine is opposite over hypotenuse
cosine of 90 minus angle is adjacent
over hypotenuse but you notice we both
got Y over one for both of those so you
can see cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse sine of 90 minus theta is ops
of hypotenuse you still get x over one
so that's why they're equivalent so you
can draw some of these triangles to help
you understand why these identities are
the way that they are but let's see if
we can do some problems and there's two
different types of we're going to be
doing one is where we're simplifying
expressions we're just trying to
condense them down as much as we can the
other type we're going to be a verifying
identities we're going to be basically
doing like a trig proof step by step
showing that the left side is identical
to the right side and so that's called
verifying identities but first let's do
some simplifying expressions so here
what we have is sine x times secant X
okay so I know secant of X is 1 over
cosine so this I could write as 1 over
cosine X sine of X is like sine over 1
and if we multiply the numerators and
denominators just like what we learned
in algebra and pre-algebra working with
fractions we can combine these and sine
over cosine we know that's tangent so
this is tangent of X and that's about as
far as we're going to be able to
condense that down okay the next one
we've got seeking to the fourth of X
minus tangent to the fourth of the X
what does that condense down to here
what we're going to do is we're going to
do some factoring so you're probably
remember from algebra the difference of
two squares so that's what we're going
to do we've got secant squared of X plus
tangent squared of x times secant
squared of X
- tangent squared of X now what does
secant squared minus tangent squared of
X equal we can see if we go over here to
the Pythagorean trig identities if we
subtract tangent squared from both sides
of this equation it's still an identity
it's still the left side is identical to
the right side so we can do that we'll
subtract tangent squared over here
secant squared minus tangent squared
equals one so this part here is one
secant squared plus tangent squared
times one is just going to be itself so
we get secant squared X plus tangent
squared X that's about as far as we're
gonna be able to reduce that one down so
here's a couple examples of working with
simplifying trigonometric expressions
now let's talk about verifying
trigonometric identities I'll write down
a few problems when you do these
problems they seem difficult at first
because it's something that you're not
used to seeing but just think of it just
like algebra you're going to be doing
factoring you're going to be working
with fractions you're gonna be getting
common denominators you're going to be
combining like terms and so on so let's
do a couple of these ones let's look at
this one here sine of X times the
cotangent of negative x okay so now look
we've got a negative angle we go to our
even and odd functions okay even an odd
identities so cotangent of negative
theta is the opposite of cotangent of
theta so let's do a substitution so this
is the same as a negative cotangent of
positive x times sine of X cotangent we
know is cosine over sine so this is
going to be negative cosine of X over
sine of X times sine of X that's the
sine of X here okay now when you
multiply fractions remember you can
cross reduce write numerator denominator
they cancel so this all reduces down to
negative cosine of X so that was just
another simplifying expression we'll get
into the identity so let's do a couple
of the verify
identities okay so let's take a look at
this one here sine of X times cosecant
of PI over 2 minus x equals tangent of X
so when you do these verifying
identities what you want to do is you
you want to work with the more expanded
side you want to condense it to the more
condensed or smaller or compact side
usually it's the left side that you're
working with and you just step by step
do your substitutions and
simplifications until you can show that
it equals the right side but you could
flip it you could start with the right
side step by step show these
substitutions and simplifications and
show that equals the left side but you
don't want to be moving anything from
left side to right side like that it's
not solving an equation it's just doing
like a trig proof and verifying one side
equals the other so cosecant of 90 minus
X we're going to go over to our Co
functions here equals secant of X so
this here is secant of x times sine of X
secant of X is equal to one over cosine
so this is 1 over cosine you can
multiply the numerators and denominators
sine over cosine equals tangent so this
is tangent of X and you can see they're
identical
so we proved it step by step you don't
want to skip too many steps you want to
show what substitutions you're making
and and simplifying and you can even go
so far as to say like I use the
reciprocal identity or I use the
cofunction or I using even an odd
identity to justify your step let's do
another example
sometimes when you're doing these
problems students get stuck and they
just say I don't know what to do so you
know I'm just gonna stop and even if you
don't know what to do one of my math
professors always just said do something
just do something because sometimes you
take that first step and that'll lead to
something else in something else and
something else and before you know it
you solved it but you have to take that
first step even though you don't
necessarily know what the next step
after that's going to be just take that
first step and if you make a mistake of
course you know you're gonna learn
something even from that mistake so
let's take a look over at this side here
okay we're gonna try to show that this
side equals this side okay notice we can
divide out a sine squared so that's
using the greatest common factor
factoring technique we learned in
algebra right so that's going to be one
minus sine squared of X so I just
factored out a sine squared so we're
just doing algebra but with trig
functions and then now we have one minus
sine squared hmm let's see
one minus sine squared if I subtract
sine squared from both sides of the
equation that leaves us with cosine
squared okay so we're gonna do that
substitution cosine square root of x
okay times sine squared of X hmm still
doesn't look like that but I notice
these are all cosines I have a sign here
still
what does sine squared equal sine
squared equals one minus cosine squared
so let's do that let's replace this with
one minus cosine squared okay
and we're going to do our distributive
property just like we learned in algebra
one right so we distribute and what do
we get cosine squared X minus cosine to
the fourth X remember when you multiply
you add the exponents if you have the
same base so it's just algebra you can
see just with trigonometric functions
and so there we go the left side equals
the right side and we proved it so get
familiar with the identities it helps if
you memorize them because when you're
doing these problems they tend to jump
off the page a little bit you say oh
that looks a lot
like this one you know usually when you
have the ones that have squares I always
think of the Pythagorean trig identities
of course if you see a negative angle
you know you're thinking of the even and
odd or if you see the PI over 2 you're
thinking of the cofunctions so we'll
start to jump jump off the page at you
you'll know what to do but if you don't
know what to do don't stop try something
make some type of substitution and see
where you can go from there if you have
to back up a couple steps
no problem erase couple steps try to go
down a different path and do a different
substitution and see where that takes
you as you do more and more of these
you'll get faster and you'll you'll
start to be able to see 2 3 4 steps
ahead and you'll know how to solve them
so this has been another video check out
some of my other past videos and I'll
see you in the next video